[Music]
how you smoke there people watch
anything particularly to idiot floats
cocking up a souffle a souffle is one of
those things I always wanted to make and
I've probably been a bit too scared it
seems very technical and the kind of
thing that always goes wrong on those
cooking contest TV shows but you seem to
think otherwise it can be quite simple
thing to do I'm old enough to remember
my mum worrying about souffles at dinner
parties is that kind of period of sort
of Fanny Cradock world science is really
kind of easy real key to it is these
these ramekin things that your mum loved
so much so when you put this foamy
mixture like I'm it's kind of like a
foamy omelette mixture you put in it and
you put it in the oven it's going to
blow up like you wouldn't believe from
all the air inside the foam expanding
and it's gonna set and as long as you
make the size of the ramekins so that
they're not going to stick it'll
literally erect itself bits of the
ramekin and come up to land is if
anything goes wrong it is profoundly
humiliating in so many sort of
psychotherapeutic ways why does it go
wrong what causes a souffle to lose its
erection probably the thing that
destroyed it for all of our mums was
neurotically peaking in the top and all
the heat comes flying out of the oven
the steams up the glasses and it wilts
first thing a little saucepan puts 40
grams of butter in it vigorously butter
the inside of all our ramekins
yeah and I'm then going to put my butter
on there on the heat you got some white
bread crumbs actually I'd blitz my snail
white bread flips it said the bread
crumbs if you can call them that mine
are more like bread lumps do you
actually own a blender I thought you did
it with a lawnmower okay that's that's
great
these go on to the bottom of the
buffeted ramekins and make sure you get
it right up the sides as well it's got
to be really properly and neatly coated
and what do they think you've got your
straight sided ramekins so there's
nothing to stop the souffle rising you
want plenty of grease on it an extra
sort of anti stick measure you
breadcrumb it to have a cellar not
brilliant this one's going a bit better
butter heat it up and then add 40 grams
of plain flour to make the roux
professional yeah the bottle of the
flower should combine remember you're
going for a couple of biscuity smell
yeah the thing that made me think of
this dish is then I ate at Shell rooster
on a few years back and he's got this
creamy cheesy souffle which is just like
nothing else I've ever tasted it's
absolutely divine you're putting me up
against Michele yeah I expect to be
impressed yeah
he's French for Christ's sake he's gonna
he's got souffle in his blood you've got
chip fat in your blood right exactly
once you've got that cooks take it off
the heat add a little bit of milk we're
going to end up putting in 300 ml of
milk we just add it a little bit at a
time off the heat whisk it till the
lumps disappear
then add a bit more but you got to put
that 100,000,000 and it's good and
smooth I then put it back on the heat
keep whisking so it goes smoother nikkor
you stir it one more time and leave it
off the heat because he wanted to drop
his temperature there do you remember
how to separate eggs I'll give it a go
yolks into one small bowl whites in a
larger bowl for whisking later so the
secret here is to kind of juggle them
from one side of the shell to the other
I think you can do it by pouring it into
your hand as well which is kind of cool
you don't keep your eggs in the fridge
deep we do sometimes yeah sorry to admit
that is that a terrible thing to confess
too
yes that's amateur mistake why is that
why should we not be keeping ace in the
fridge you can't really make a meringue
so what we'll be making in a minute with
Comex they won't work or they'll get the
meringue to set if you're the kind of
person who uses one egg every two months
then keep them in the fridge but
otherwise keep your eggs outside they're
always ready to use 50 grams of parmesan
break that and beat it into our bechamel
about a hundred grams of career to go in
as well don't put it on the heat sorry
in cold there so this is forming a kind
of a lumpy claggy paste yep
add the egg yolks and stir those into
this is all off the heat you certainly
don't any heat map did you basically
just make it scrambled eggs this point
you can also season it Tom pepper a
little bit of salt not too much to the
parmesan salty and the green air salty
pepper yeah good idea so what does the
consistency be like this mine's quite
lumpy well kind of sloppy scrambled eggs
now this is the bit which is already
separate the men from the boys taking
the egg whites and beating them up into
our meringue I'm gonna use one of these
they're terribly 1970s retro
it's starting to get a little sweats on
here no sir it was gonna be easy babe my
eggs have been confiscated off me and
are now being beaten by director of
photography that's stiff isn't it
perhaps you should ask your wife take a
spoonful of your ring see a custard
gently within it doesn't mix completely
all you're doing is using the foam to
lighten the custard and then by the
third or fourth spoonful you'll see
you're getting a very very light and
mixture so the key here is there is a
sort of a light touch a very light touch
you want to move your spatula through
this stuff as little as you can
you've got it you've got it what I like
about this is I mean you can talk about
this all you like and you can read as
many instructions as you want but when
you actually have the tools in your hand
you can see what it's doing the science
kind of dictates it for you you can see
you're trying to keep the air trapped in
there but you do want to combine it but
not so much it's going to be a problem
shallow baking tray that I put all my
ramekins inside it carefully spoon the
mixture until they're about
three-quarters full
pour boiling water in around the pots
into the baking tray creating something
called a ban Murray to stop the heat
aggressively overcooking put it into the
oven and start a timer
all those trapped bubbles that you
carefully preserved are now going to
expand the worst thing we could possibly
do right now is crack and peek we let
the air out and the whole thing will
floor what's really being exposed as how
little we clean our oven door it's not a
great view in there I wonder if we're
discovering something interesting here
about the 1970s cook looking through the
window of that thing I mean about now if
I had a dinner party full of people
outside
I'd be bloody terrified when I take a
peek this is exactly why I've never I've
never cooked it for a dinner party
because I just know it's one of those
things that would fail and already I'm
feeling the pressure if you're not one
of those there's plastic and chocolate
fondants or something we were you know
where the chocolate isn't run in the
middle how you smoke there people watch
anything particularly to idiot blokes
cocking up a souffle is this the kind of
thing that you would cook often a
souffle haven't done a souffle in years
but but it has a massive emotional
connection because I just remember how
important things like that with someone
mum I can imagine what the the menu
would be like at that
a party it would it would start with a
prawn cocktail then you have a cheese
soufflé and he'll probably end on the
Black Forest gateau Oh almost certainly
yes yes no will they collapse they won't
collapse
Oh blimey that is good I think the extra
height would have been a more impressive
visual treat for 1970 thinner party but
there's certainly nothing wrong with
that to eat it's absolutely delicious
that's an OL thingy size just everything